[Música]
el balotaje es una realidad en Guatemala
y para la sorpresa del país un candidato
de Centro izquierda Se ganó su cupo para
competir por la presidencia del 20 de
agosto Pese a que no era favorecido por
las encuestas se trata de Juan José
Arévalo quien se enfrentará a la
derechista Es primera dama Sandra Torres
la jornada de este domingo estuvo
marcada sin embargo por disturbios que
incluyeron la quema de papeletas El
lanzamiento de artefactos explosivos y
también la renuncia de jurados por
amenazas pese a todos según cifras
preliminares esta cita contó con una
alta participación vamos a dar la
bienvenida a nuestra primera invitada
del día Carmen Rosa de León escribano
quienes investigadora del instituto de
enseñanza para el desarrollo sostenible
y Epa de Guatemala Muchísimas gracias
Rosa y bienvenida
Gracias y buenos días a todas y todos
por esta entrevista Bueno hablemos
primero de Arévalo Bernardo Arévalo para
hacer la corrección que fue la sorpresa
de la elección Y qué fue lo que impulsó
sus apoyos contra el dictamen que daban
las encuestas Bueno yo creo que hubo
varios fenómenos o sea efectivamente
como se Ustedes han planteado si había
todo un mecanismo
fraudulento desde el principio de las
elecciones que fue eliminar candidatos
posibles cada vez que un candidato subía
primer lugar era eliminado también lo
que vimos ayer que ustedes ya
mencionaron que era el acarreo de
personas que no pertenecían a un
municipio a votar en otro los disturbios
también que se dieron pero sobre todo
hubo un fenómeno que en realidad el que
ganó fue el voto nulo es decir la gente
rechazó el sistema la gente rechazó
por fraudulentas o por no confiar en el
proceso electoral y también por las
acciones que se cometido varios
candidatos eliminados también llamaron
al voto nulo esto creo que dio la
posibilidad de tener un resultado
inesperado realmente que fue apoyar
sobre todo y subir por precisamente por
el efecto del voto nulo subieron algunos
candidatos que tenían sus cuotas es
decir el partido semilla el cual
pertenece Bernardo Arévalo es un partido
que ha ganado desde las elecciones
pasadas en el en el área metropolitana
del país y sobre todo en el área urbana
del interior y esto creo que promovió
Pues que por el efecto precisamente de
esa voto nulo y una abstención pues del
40% eh creo que eso propició que pudiera
entrar este candidato a una segunda
vuelta tenemos que ver sin embargo Pues
que sobre todo en el ámbito del Congreso
si se mantuvo una fuerza del partido de
gobierno que ya había hecho algunas
alianzas con los alcaldes locales y con
candidatos locales para mantener su
fuerza en el congreso esto nos lleva
Pues a un escenario complicado donde hay
un movimiento que sí logra bastantes
candidatos pero no va a superar el el
reparto en el congreso que va a seguir
perteneciendo a los partidos que hasta
ahora pues hemos llamado El pacto de
corruptos es decir los partidos que
están gobernando y que están gobernando
en conjunto Pero entonces Carmen lo que
nos queda claro es que el partido de
gobierno cuyo candidato quedó en tercer
lugar va a tener un papel muy importante
en este balotaje del 20 de agosto
hablemos ahora de Sandra Torres que
lidera la unidad nacional de la
esperanza de Centro izquierda y hago
énfasis en esto porque la postura de
Sandra es a todas luces de derecha por
qué caló esta si se le puede llamar de
alguna manera incoherencia política en
la candidata Sandra Torres
Bueno lo que sucede es que de alguna
forma en las mismas reglas del juego que
el mismo tribunal supremo electoral
había planteado y el mismo gobierno
hacían que hubiera un discurso que
Aparentemente era hacia la derecha a un
contra la agenda 2030 en muchos de los
casos es decir la competencia se daba en
en el margen de creer que Guatemala es
un pueblo conservador Pues que
seguramente todavía en algunas áreas lo
es y que entonces era el discurso este
conservador el que iba el que iba a
traer más más votos y creo que ahí Esa
esa pequeña esa gran contradicción
verdad porque realmente Sandra Torres
incluso es entiendo yo miembro de la
internacional socialista pero se ha
demarcado en estas elecciones con un
discurso bastante conservador sin
embargo ella tiene Pues un piso muy muy
fuerte de cuando ella fue primera dama e
hizo muchos programas en el país bien
pero previo a los comicios justamente
sobre estas posturas políticas algo que
estaba en el ambiente y que preocupaba
era que Los favoritos firmaron una
suerte de compromiso con organizaciones
provida defensa de la familia
tradicional grupos en contra de los
derechos reproductivos contra el
colectivo de la comunidad diversa A qué
se enfrentan entonces las mujeres y las
minorías cuando hablamos de la
posibilidad de estos candidatos Bueno yo
creo que el mismo Triunfo de semilla es
un respaldo a un discurso diferente a un
discurso que realmente pues es un
digamos incluyente y representativo
entonces creo que por un lado el
discurso de semilla pues representa el
rechazo a esa a esa propuesta
conservadora que habían traído el resto
de partidos es una propuesta diferente y
por otro lado también
pues de todas formas no debemos negar
que estamos en un
impuesto por el autoritarismo del
partido en este momento en el poder y
por el presidente Jean maté que se ha
trasladado desde el gobierno anterior
justamente cuando unieron fuerzas todo
los sectores conservadores incluyendo el
empresariado fuerte para expulsar a la
comisión internacional contra la
impunidad Ese es el ámbito en el que se
está jugando estas elecciones muy
es muy muy atadas por el pacto de El
pacto de por la captura de las
instituciones que existe en Guatemala
donde el tribunal supremo electoral el
Ministerio Público también con una
justicia totalmente amañada para para
atacar a los opositores pues son es un
marco muy estrecho que ha hecho que
muchos candidatos tengan que variar su
discurso para no ser eliminados de la
contienda mire pero es que justamente
años atrás esta nación se ha entrenado a
centroamericana tenía un panorama bien
distinto llegó a ser un ejemplo de
Bonanza económica de lucha contra la
corrupción pero en la actualidad Esta es
una problemática que como ustedes bien
ha dicho ha marcado a los recientes
gobiernos Cómo se llegó a este punto
pues se llegó precisamente porque cuando
la comisión internacional contra la
impunidad empezó a evidenciar los pactos
que había habido entre determinados
sectores empresariales históricos y
oligárquicos y
políticos sobre todo para mantener los
privilegios que se estaban que que tenía
este grupo oligárquico lo que sucedió
fue que se unieron absolutamente todos
para expulsar a la comisión
internacional contra la impunidad esto
hizo que hubiera un desde antes de este
gobierno A mediados del anterior pues
desde la expulsión de lo que hubo fue
una paulatina captura del estado es
decir fueron capturando sobre todo la
justicia fue una de las primeras que que
que el estado no dejó que se cambiaran
magistrados de la Corte Suprema de
Justicia precisamente para poder seguir
teniendo ese
de corruptos como la llamamos para y
manejar desde la acusación la
persecución y la justicia a los
opositores políticos y eliminar a todo
aquello que tuviera que ver con los
casos de la de hecho pues hemos visto
como la justicia se ha encarnizado en
periodistas Fiscales y líderes sociales
y ha dejado libres a todos aquellos que
habían sido acusados por corrupción
dentro de las investigaciones de la
sisic O sea hubo ese cambio y por eso
necesitaban tener esa captura del Estado
incluyendo el tribunal supremo electoral
para poder realmente
manejar todos los hilos que en este caso
vemos que es que no les funcionó pues
mire Muchísimas gracias hay mucho tema
todavía para hablar sobre el país y
tendremos plazo para Estos espacios
hasta el balotaje ese Carmen Rosa de
León escribano investigadora del
instituto de enseñanza para el
desarrollo sostenible de Guatemala un
placer y que tenga feliz día
gracias y gracias a ustedes por cubrir
esta noticia agradecimiento también para
nuestros televidentes que están a esta
hora conectados con directo a América
quédense ya volvemos con más
[Música]